Đầu trước y tế thử dơ về ké phát ông Truy biet đang theo dõi chạp chè ổ dựng video sân hành ta
liên quan đến su tuyền Andy Hodgers. Đừng thơ kèng báo khả năng su tiện thêm
căniệm trong những tổn tối, dò thử dân uệnh kéo dài.
Cũng theo về ké phát ông, ổ dự suốt phát đoạn chình của su tuyền Andy Hodgers,
với nhất bà chính hợp tử vong và nhiều căniệm được sân dạc, khả một số cu sai.
Phà bản nhân nghiênm chẳng nhất đang lự đuổi trị tích cực, trong đó có chính hợp phải hỗ trợ
tìm phủ nhân tạo. Tổn giống đông về ké phát ông Truy J Rose and Hanh Nông,
Gabriel Jesus, Nhân Mạnh, chưa có giấu hiệu dịch lăng dạo trong cộng đồng.
Tuy nhiên, nguy cơ xuất hiện thêm các bạn là có cơ sở, so đặc tình lấy chuyên của
video s vát thử dân uệnh có thiệm kéo dài tưởng phay tôn.
Về các phát ông Truy biet đã ginh nhận biển thề,暫 jét xuất video sân ta, trong một dịch.
Có khả năng lấy từ động vận gặp giấm sang người, và trong một số chuyên hợp hiếm có thể lấy từ người sang người
khi tiếp xúc gần. Tất của gia linh qua là chiến khai biển phát cách li, theo dõi tế đồ bia hình khách, và nhân tên lấy tế tình tiếp xúc với các bạn.
Bây các phát ông cũng khuyên cạo suy chi giám 30 tế, đồng thời áp dụng,
quý trình cách li trong ý nhất bốn miệng hàng ngày, đồ với các nhóm huy cơ cao nhằm ngâm trạm vi cơ lấy làm tiếp theo.